I want to go back to the guy that's
unable to make it rain because I think
that's interesting right it's like again
what does he bring to the table aside
from love that we keep you around and
now you're married okay so you've made a
commitment you've decided to go all in
you've taken your vows like you guys did
like a religious ceremony sickness and
health till death do his part all that
sort of stuff was it like a Christian
Catholic Ceremony was it a Muslim
ceremony like how'd you do it so when I
when I got to Egypt you're not allowed
to really like be intimate with that
person if you're not married so we did
like a Muslim type of ceremony when I
got there when we got back to the us we
did you know
the justice of the peace we went down
and we just um okay you know signed so
what's the tolerance level like how long
did you keep him around before you're
like [__] this him out too long um how
many
years about seven seven years and then
yeah were you out earning him all seven
years I'm sorry were you out earning him
all seven
years yeah I I have I haven't stopped
working since I was
13 like like out earning him by a
massive margin like he didn't bring
anything home he didn't contribute
anything he didn't start making money
really
until I opened the store for him and I
had to hold his hand to do all that it
was really my store was he bringing in
money when you guys said I do
the only money he had was money from his
family family money yeah and did that
stop coming or did it continue to come
it stopped because stopped why did it
stop and in fact I had to start sending
money to his mom who she was a very nice
woman great woman you know but just in
these countries they don't really give
help to the elderly they they don't have
like Social Security and things you know
like like they do here so right
M you're gonna ask something sorry no I
was asking like seven years from the
time she discovered the coke habit or
just seven years no this is a different
person no this is the
Egyptian is another guy we'll get to the
Cokey in
[Laughter]
minute got it me it really sounds like
you've you've created your own
boundaries now like you've you've kind
of figured it out and you created your
own boundaries but also seems like
you've had like a really big heart that
you let so many people in like these men
and you would just you know care for
them and care for them and care for them
and keep trying to make it work because
you're such like a big-hearted person so
I don't think that means you're you know
you did anything wrong I just think like
you finally figured out your boundaries
and what you want and how to like get to
your your next step in your
goal you know and it took me a long time
don't make that mistake you girls are
young don't do that was was this guy a
handsome man he was was he great in the
bedroom he was okay yeah so okay so now
we're getting down to the reason why the
the marriage lasted for a few years but
you know like I've said you know women
women don't have a lot of patience for a
guy that can't make it rain right I mean
your good looks in your in your bedroom
Acumen will only last for so long before
she's like
so I can get this somewhere else and I
don't to take care of this person right
it gets frustrating doesn't it you know
it's not about though like I I have
never been a person that I would ever
ever look to somebody to take care of me
or support me I've always made my own
money I will always make my own money
till the day that I die I don't think
there's a woman out there today that
wouldn't like to be a like a taking care
of woman though right I don't like to be
taken care of if a guy came along and
said Samantha look I make you know a
million bucks a year we're good you if
you want to keep doing the engineering
thing awesome but there are strings
attached I'm going to swap out your car
we're g to get you a brand new S-Class
Mercedes SUV or something like that look
if he wants to be you wouldn't say no to
it would you if he wants to be in my
life and we grow together and we're
Partners together then yeah but I mean
you're not really Partners if he's
making a million bucks and you're making
100,000 right like he's still relation
always have my own money you will of
course but you would be okay with him
offering upgrades to your lifestyle yeah
yeah like when you say strings attach
like what do you
mean I I can't be this type of person
where I take like all of my my um my
livelihood and give it to somebody else
to make like I have no problem and I
livelihood like like giving him your
paycheck to just say manage the finances
or no like like
like just stay home and do
nothing I can't do that do you want to
have
children I don't I don't know honestly
what's the next step for you because
you're 35 and you want to get married
you want to have kids like what's I'm
not in a rush to do any of that you're
dating with what intentions right right
now I am I'm working on a project that I
really enjoy at work at work okay um
it's an airport job and um I'm just
having a blast and I'm doing a [__] ton
of
traveling and um you know I think you
know there are women out there that are
like desperate to have kids and this and
that and I've just never been one of
those people you know if I had a a a
relationship where I ended up
pregnant I would of course be happy you
know if that's where my life LED um but
I'm not uh I'm not like really in a rush
to do any of
that um Kenzie what do you guys
think see reaction there I I I get it I
totally get the like feeling that way of
like you're not really in a rush like if
it happens it happens but like not
trying to force it I also understand in
like the whole like red winner kind of
thing it'd be hella nice to walk into a
relationship and have like the person
that like respects you and like treats
you the way that you like deserve to be
treated also was capable of like
treating you special
financially so like I kind of get where
she stands on a lot of her points but I
definitely couldn't have done the seven
marriage taking care of someone else in
their family I could not do that like
cheers you man but like I would have
been out of there like the second time
he asked me for money I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe here and pin down below in
the top comment you'll find a bunch of
useful links to my website my supplement
line books and a bunch of other stuff
have an amazing day peace out